as we celebrate black history month
we're highlighting one of the first
black officers in the army
special forces the famous green berets
the courage and valor of retired colonel
paris davis
earned him the respect of his fellow
soldiers in vietnam
and a nomination for the nation's
highest military combat award
he never received the medal of honor his
file vanished
at the height of the civil rights
movement now nearly 56 years later
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge shows
how davis heroism may finally be
recognized
1965 in washington
anti-war protests raged
bloody sunday in selma alabama
galvanized the civil rights movement
and in vietnam then army captain paris
davis
broke barriers on the battlefield were
you one of the first
black officers in the green berets yes i
was
how did that work worked well because i
said look
you can call me captain davis but you
can't call me in there
and it did happen northeast of saigon
near bongson
june 1965 davis led a nearly
19-hour raid we were stacking bodies
the way you do canned goods in a grocery
store
hit by a grenade and gunfire davis would
not leave behind
americans billy waugh and robert brown
both
gravely injured brown had been shot i
could actually
see his his brain pulsating it was
it was that big and he said um
am i going to die and i i said not
before me
were you ever told to leave well
twice as davis first revealed in 1969
to an up-and-coming local tv host phil
donahue
i told him sir i'm just not going to
leave i still have an american out there
and what did he say he told me to uh to
move out
and uh i just disobeyed the order
there by davis side ron dice now the
team's youngest survivor
captain davis refused and said no i'm
not leaving
well
i'm not leaving while i have men out of
the field
general westmoreland who led u.s forces
in vietnam
visited davis outpost and his commander
billy cole recommended davis for the
medal of honor
and then somehow the paperwork vanished
in vietnam
a 1969 military review did not reveal
any file on davis what makes the pierce
davis case stand out
that it was lost everybody i've talked
to that served under him says
he's the best officer they've ever
served under what really stands out to
me
neil thorne volunteers his time to
recover medals for
overlooked veterans how common is it for
medal of honor paperwork
to be lost or destroyed very uncommon
there would have been
multiple copies in 1969 the army was
ordered to submit
new paperwork asap for davis and for a
second time
there is no evidence a medal of honor
file was created
in a 1981 statement billy wa whom davis
carried on his shoulders to safety wrote
i only have to close my eyes to vividly
recall
the gallantry of this individual over
the years
davis's teammates also lobbied congress
but each time
the process stalled do you think race
was a factor
i don't think i know race was a factor
a factor davis says he experienced
during his 23 years in the army
he recalls an encounter with another
pilot he rescued
while on a different mission i saw him
at fort bragg
with his wife and his kid they saw me he
went on the other side of the street so
he wouldn't have to speak
if that had been a white guy you know
he'd gone over
and hugged him that's racism eight
percent of medal of honor recipients for
vietnam
were black now as he approaches his 82nd
birthday
there is new momentum to recognize davis
we're all trying to right or wrong the
army
isn't commenting an expedited review of
davis's loss nomination is due next week
the final call rests with the defense
secretary and president biden
what would it mean to you it would mean
all the things that i haven't been able
to dream about for cbs this morning
catherine herridge strasburg virginia
catherine herridge i'm speechless thank
you so much for bringing us that story
talk about righting or wrong
well talk about writing a wrong and
where you have people in his own command
that said
i wouldn't be here if it not for him yes
and and actually brought to tears
recalling the the episode gotta make
that right you're watching cbs
this morning we'll be right back